Hey,
thanks very much for the invitation to
speak to you.
Um,
yeah,
so I'm going to be talking about deep
generative models.
Um,
so when we talk about deep generative
models,
what we're really talking about here
from my point of view is to essentially
train neural nets,
uh,
from training examples in order to
represent,
uh,
the distribution from which these came.
So we can think about this as either
explicitly doing density estimation
where we have some samples here and we
try to model those samples with some
density estimation.
Or we can think of it more like a this,
which is what actually I'll be doing a
lot more of this kind of thing,
which is to essentially we're worried
about sample generation here.
So we have some training examples like
this where we're sort of just natural
images from the world and we're asked
the asking a model to train,
to learn to output images like this.
Now,
uh,
these are actually not true samples.
These are actually just other images
from the same trainings.
I believe this is from image net.
Uh,
a few years ago or even a few months
ago,
this would have seemed obvious that
this,
you couldn't generate samples like this,
but in fact nowadays,
this is actually not so obvious that we
couldn't generate these.
So it's been a very exciting time in
this area,
in the amount of work we've done in the
amount of progress we've made in the
last few years has been pretty
remarkable.
And so I think part of what I want to do
here is tell you a little bit about that
progress.
Give you some sense of where we were in
say 2014 when this started really to
accelerate and,
and where we are now.
So,
yeah.
so why generative models?
Why do we care about gender to modeling?
Well,
there's a,
there's a bunch of reasons.
Some of us are just really interested in
making pretty pictures.
And I confess that for the most part,
that's what I'll be showing you today is
just as an evaluation metric,
uh,
we'll,
we'll just be looking at,
at pictures,
I'm just natural images and how well
we're doing in natural images.
But there's actually real tasks that we
care about when we talk about gender to
modeling.
One of them is just,
let's say you want to do some
conditional generation,
like for example,
machine translation,
right?
So we're conditioning on some source
sentence and we want to output some,
uh,
target sentence.
Will the structure within that target
sentence that the target language,
let's say that the,
the rules,
the grammatical rules,
you can model that structure using a
generative model.
So this is an instance of where we would
do conditional generative modeling.
Another example,
uh,
where,
this is something that we're actually
looking a little bit towards is,
is can we use generative models is
outlier detection.
And actually recently these types of
models have been integrated into rl
algorithms to help them do exploration
more effectively.
This was duct work done,
um,
at deep mind,
I believe.
Uh,
so here we're,
we're,
we're looking at,
you know,
a case where,
if you can think about kind of a,
this is a toy toyish version of the
autonomous vehicle,
the task,
and you want to be able to distinguish
cars and wheelchairs and then you're
going to have something like this and
you don't want your classifier to just
blindly say,
oh,
I think it's either a car or a
wheelchair.
You want your classifier to understand
that this is an outlier,
right?
And you can use generative modeling to
be able to do that by noticing that
there aren't very many things like this
example from the training set.
So you can proceed with caution.
And this is kind of a big deal,
right?
Because we don't want,
our classifiers are,
our neural net classifiers are very,
very capable of,
of doing excellent performance
classification.
But,
but any classifiers just trained to
output one of the classes that it's been
given.
And so,
uh,
in cases where we actually are faced
with something really new and that's not
seen before or perhaps a illumination
conditions that it's never been trained
to,
to cope with.
We want models that are conservative in
those cases.
So we hope to be able to use generative
models for that.
Another case where we're looking at
generative models being useful is in
going from simulation to real,
uh,
examples of in robotics.
So,
so in robotics training these robots
with neural nets is actually quite
laborious.
If you're really trying to do this on
the real robot,
it would take many,
many trials and it's,
it's not really practical in simulation.
This works much,
much better.
But the problem is,
is that if you train a policy and
simulation and transfer it to the real
robot,
well that's not going to work well.
That hasn't worked very well because the
environment is just too different.
But what if we could use a generative
model to make our simulations so
realistic that that transfer is viable?
So this is the one,
another area that a number of groups are
looking at this kind of x pushing gender
modeling in this direction.
So there's lots of really practical ways
to use generate models beyond just
looking at pretty pictures.
Um,
right.
So,
so I,
I break down the kinds of generative
models there are in the world and to two
rough categories here.
And maybe we can take issue with this.
Oh,
by the way,
if you guys have questions,
go ahead and ahead and ask me a while.
You have them.
I think I,
I like interaction as possible or you
can just save them to the end.
Either way is fine.
Um,
and sorry for my voice,
I've got a cold.
Uh,
so yeah,
we have auto regressive models and we
have latent variable models.
So auto regressive models are models
where you basically define an ordering
over your input,
right?
So for things like speech recognition or
strather speech synthesis and the gender
and modeling case,
this is natural,
right?
It's just,
there's a natural ordering to that data.
It's just the temporal sequence for
things like images.
It's a little less obvious how you would
define an ordering over pixels.
But there are nonetheless models such as
a pixel rnn and Pixel cnn that do just
this.
In fact,
pixel CNN is a,
is a really interesting model from this
point of view.
They basically define a convolutional
neural net with a mask.
So if you remember our previous lecture
we did,
we saw these convolutional neural nets,
but what they do is they stick a mask on
it so that you've got sort of a causal
direction.
So you're only looking at previous
pixels in the ordering that you've
defined the,
the,
um,
well,
the ordering that defined by the,
the auto regressive model.
So,
so you kind of maintain this,
this ordering as you go through the
confident and what that allows you to do
is come up with a generative model
that's supported by this continent,
uh,
that,
you know,
it's just a full generative model and
it's a,
it's a pretty interesting model in its
own right.
But because of I have rather limited
time,
I'm actually not going to go into that
model in particular.
Another thing I just want to point out
here is that wave net is probably the
state of the art model for speech
synthesis right now.
And it forms the basis of a very
interesting speech synthesis systems.
It's another area where gender models
have made remarkable contributions in
the last few years,
even the last few months.
So now we're seeing models that you
would be fairly hard pressed to
distinguish between natural speech and
and these kinds of models for the most
part.
So what I'm going to concentrate on is a
latent variable models.
So latent variable models are models
that essentially posit that you have
some latent variables that are hope that
you hope will represent some latent
factors of variation in the data,
right?
So these are,
these are things that as you wiggle
them,
they're going to move the data in,
in what you hope will be natural ways.
Right?
So you can imagine a latent variable for
images corresponding to illumination
conditions,
right?
Or if their faces a common,
it's a common thing.
We find is latent variable corresponded
to a smart,
right?
So if we move this latent variable,
the image that we see that we generate,
you know,
a smile appears and disappears and these
are the kind of latent variables that we
want and we want to discover these.
So this is really a challenging task in
general.
We want to take natural data,
just unlabeled data and discover these
latent factors that give rise to the
variation.
We see there's two kinds of models in
this family that I'm going to be talking
about.
A adversarial auto encoders and
generative adversarial nets are gans
here.
Uh,
I work personally with both of these
kinds of models.
They serve different purposes for me.
And,
uh,
yeah,
well let's,
let's dive in a,
so first I'll talk about,
uh,
the variation all encoders.
This actually was a model was developed
simultaneously by two different groups.
One at a deep mind is the bottom one
here and then a king man dwelling at the
University of Amsterdam.
So again,
the idea behind the,
uh,
the,
the well latent variable models in
general is kind of represented in this
picture,
right?
So here's the space of our latent
variables and we consist this kind of
represented as being fairly simple.
And we have our two coordinate zed one
and zed too.
And they're independent in this case and
they're sort of fairly regular and they
sort of form a chart for what is our
complicated distribution here in,
in,
in x space,
right?
So this is,
you can think of this as third of the
data manifold.
So you can think of this as image space
for example,
right?
So image space embedded in pixel space,
natural images,
embedded pixel space form,
this kind of manifold.
And what we want is coordinates that
allow you to,
as you move sort of smoothly in this
space,
move along this what can be a very
complicated manifold.
And so that's the kind of hope.
What that,
what,
what we're looking for when we do latent
variable modeling.
So here's just an example of,
of what I mean by exactly that.
This is an early example using these
various channel auto encoders.
So here's a,
the fray face data set,
just a whole bunch of images of Brendan
phrase face.
Uh,
that's in the Dataset.
What we're showing here is the model,
the,
the model output,
uh,
of this variational auto encoder for
different values of these latent
variable zed one in zed to now we've
kind of post hoc added these labels,
pose and expression on them because you
see if as we move the zed to here,
you can see the expression kind of
smoothly changes from what looks like a
frown to eventually smile and through
what looks over here like a stinging as
well.
Sticking his tongue out,
I guess.
Uh,
and in this direction there's a slight
head turn.
It's pretty subtle,
but it's there.
So,
so we did,
like I said,
these were sort of post hoc,
added the model just discovered that
these were two sources of variation in
the data,
that we're relatively independent.
And the model just pulled those out for
something like amnesty.
This is the,
these are samples drawn on a model
trained by ethnicity.
It's a little less natural,
right?
Because in this case,
you could,
you could argue the data.
It's really best model as something not
with Leighton factors like continuously
and factors,
but more like in clusters.
So you get this kind of somewhat
interesting,
somewhat bizarre relationship where you
know,
you've got some of this relationship
with tilt happens here,
but then the ones heard of morphs into a
seven,
which morphs into a nine.
And you know,
because these different regions in this
continuous space that represent
different examples here.
So a little bit more detail into how we
do these kinds of a latent variable
models,
at least in the context of the
variational auto encoder or va model.
Um,
so what we're trying to learn here is,
is p of x some distribution over the
data.
We're trying to maximize the likelihood
of the data.
That's it.
But the way we're going to parameterize
our model is with a p of x given zed zed
or is our latent variables,
I'm sorry to Z,
I guess for you guys.
Uh,
p of x given Z and then P of Z,
right?
Some,
some prior distribution.
Right?
So this P of z here is,
is typically something simple,
right?
It's some prior distribution.
We actually generally want it to be
independent.
There's some modeling compromises to be
made there.
But the reason why you'd want it
independent is because that helps get
you the kind of orthogonal
representation here.
So these guys,
this dimension and this dimension,
we want sort of not very much
interaction in order to make them more
interpretable.
Um,
yeah.
And so,
and the other thing we want to do is we
want to think about how are we going to,
so,
so going from something simple,
like you can think about this as like in
a Gaussian distribution or a uniform
distribution,
but now we want a model g here that
transforms zed from this space into this
complicated space.
And the way we're going to do that is
with a neural net.
Actually,
in all of the examples that I'm going to
show you today,
the way we're going to do that is with a
convolutional neural net.
And the way to think about that,
it's a bit of an interesting thing to
think about going from some fully
connected things that into some two
dimensional input with a typology here
in the natural image space x.
And so it's just the way going from a,
what we talked about,
it's kind of like the opposite path of
where you would take to do a confidante
classification.
Um,
there's a few different ways you could
think about doing that.
One of which is called a transposed
convolution.
This turns out to not to be such a good
idea.
Uh,
this is a case where you essentially
fill in a bunch of Zeros.
Uh,
it seems like the most acceptable way to
do that right now is to just,
once you get some small level typology
here,
you just,
you do interpolation.
So you just,
you know,
super sample from the image.
Uh,
you can do by linear interpolation and
then do a conflict preserves that size.
And then up sample again,
comp up,
sample comp,
that tends to give you the best results.
So,
right?
So when you see this kind of thing,
this kind of thing for our purposes,
think convolutional neural net.
All right?
So it's important to point out that that
if we had,
uh,
if we had over here,
ceds that go went,
where's this [inaudible] that went with
our ex,
uh,
we'd be done right?
Because this is just a supervised
learning problem at this point.
And we'd be fine.
The trick is these are latent,
right?
Need their hidden.
We don't know these sets.
We don't have,
we haven't discovered them yet.
So how do we learn with this model?
Well,
the way we're going to do it is we're
going to use a trick that's actually
been around for quite some time.
Uh,
it says,
this isn't particularly new.
We're going to use a variation lower
bound on the data likelihood,
right?
So it turns out that we can actually
express,
uh,
the,
the data likelihood heard.
Again,
this is the thing we're trying to
maximize.
We can express a lower bound for it
given by something like that.
So we posit that we have some cue
distribution of zed that estimates is
the posterior of zed for a given X.
And we're trying to then um,
I guess maximize this joint probability
over x and zed minus the log cues that,
so this is,
this is this variation of lower bound.
Um,
one of the ways we can express this is
you're trying to find the cute from
[inaudible] point of view is if you were
to find a cue that actually recovered
the exact posterior distribution over
zed given x,
this would actually be a tight,
lower bound,
right?
So then we would for sure be optimizing
if we were at all now optimize this
lower boundary would be for sure,
optimizing likelihood in practice.
That's what we're going to do anyway.
We're going to have this lower bound,
we're going to try to optimize it.
We're trying to raise that up in hopes
of raising up our likelihood.
Um,
but the problem is this posterior,
the actual posterior of,
of say of this g model here,
this neural net,
right?
This is just some forward model neural
net.
So computing the posterior of zed given
acts and tractable.
We have no good way of doing this.
It's going to be some complicated thing
and we have no sensible way of doing
this,
so we're going to approximate it with
this queue in this way.
So we're going to,
now we can actually,
and what's interesting about this
formulation,
and this is this is new to the
variation.
A lot of queries they've started or just
reformulated this a little bit
differently and what they've got is they
come up with this,
this different expression here,
which actually can be thought of in two
terms here.
One is the reconstruction term here.
If you look at what this is,
this is just,
you get some from some queue,
you get a zed and you're just trying to
reconstruct x from that said,
so you start with x,
you get a zed,
and then you're trying to do a
reconstruction of x.
From that said,
this is where the name variational auto
encoder comes from is because this
really looks like an encoder on the side
of queue here and a decoder here,
and you're just trying to minimize that
reconstruction error.
But in addition to this,
they add this regularization term,
and this is interesting,
right?
So this is what they're doing here is
they're basically saying,
well,
we want to regularize this posterior and
there's actually new auto encoders don't
have this,
right?
So I'm just trying to regularize this
posterior to try to be a little bit
closer to the prior here.
And it's a common mistake when people
learn about this to sort of think that,
oh well the goal is for these things to
actually match.
That would be terrible,
right?
That means that you lose all information
about x.
You definitely don't want these things
to match.
But it does act as a regular riser,
sort of as a counterpoint to this
reconstruction term.
And so now we've talked a little bit
about this,
but what is this queue?
Well,
for the variation of wind coated,
the queues going to be another neural
net.
And in this case we can think of it.
This is just a straight confident for
the case of natural images.
So again,
we've got our lower bound,
their objective that we're trying to
minimize and we're going to parameterize
q as this neural net confident that goes
from x to zed and we've got now are
generative model here are decoder that
goes from zed to x.
Um,
I'm going to add a few more details to
make this thing actually Prac in
practice.
I've till now,
this is not to uh,
new,
there's been instances of this kind of
formalism of an encoder network and a
decoder network,
but what they do next is actually kind
of interesting.
They notice that that if they
parameterize this a certain way,
if they say q is equal to it,
actually you can use any continuous
distribution here,
but they pick a,
a normal distribution here.
So q of x is some normal distribution
where the parameters mew in sigma from
the defined this normal distribution are
defined by this encoder network.
Then they can actually encode it.
Like this is called the reprioritization
trick,
where they take said our random variable
here is equal to some function of the
input.
Mew Plus Sigma are scaling factor over
some noise.
And what this allows us to do now when
they formulate it this way,
is the one in training.
This model,
they can actually back prop through the
decoder and into the encoder to train
both models simultaneously.
It looks a little bit like this.
So they can do for propagation,
start with an ex forward propagate to
zed add noise here.
That was that epsilon.
And then for propagate here to this x Ha
hat,
which is our reconstruction,
compute the air between x and x hat and
back,
propagate that error all the way
through.
And that allows them to actually train
this model very effectively in ways that
we've never been able to train before
this.
This card trick came up and when you do
that,
this is the kind of thing that came out.
So this came out in 2014.
These are actually really,
I promise these were really impressive
results in,
in 2014.
Um,
the first time we were seeing,
so this is not a,
this is from the FDA labeled facing the
wild these days we use celebrate,
um,
and uh,
this is imaging it.
So,
so not a whole lot there.
Actually,
this is a small version of image net.
Um,
but you can do things with this model
actually.
So for example,
one of the things that we've done with
this model is we actually just,
we talked to,
I mentioned briefly this pixel,
CNN,
we,
we actually include this pixel cnn into
the decoder side.
So one of the problems,
if I just go back,
one of the problems why we get these
kinds of images is this model makes a
lot of independence assumptions,
right?
And part of it is,
is because we want those independents
assumptions to make hers eds more
interpretable,
but they have consequences to them.
And one of the consequences is you end
up with kind of blurry images.
That's,
that's part of why you end up with
biliary images because we're making
these approximations in the variational,
um,
lower bound.
And so by adding the pixel CNN that
allows us to encode more complexity in
here.
And by the way,
this is now a hierarchical version of
the vie using pixel CNN that Lowe's,
the law allows us to encode sort of
complicated distributions in zed one
here,
uh,
given the,
the upper levels eds and with this kind
of thing,
uh,
this is the kind of images that we can
just synthesize using this variational.
Uh,
we'll call this the,
the pixel vie model.
So a bedroom,
these are bedrooms scenes,
uh,
so you can sort of see it's reasonably
good clear bedroom scenes.
And then image net,
which you're,
that,
you know,
you can see that it gets roughly the,
the texture's,
right?
It's not really getting objects yet.
Actually objects that are really tough
to get when you model things in an
unconditional way.
What I mean by that is the model doesn't
know that it's supposed to generate a
dog,
let's say if it was going to generate
something.
So it's just generating from p of x in
general.
And it's actually pretty challenging
when we talk about image net.
All right.
So,
so that's one way we can improve the uh,
the va model.
Another way we can improve the Vau
models work on the encoder side.
And that was done,
uh,
by uh,
a few people but culminating I think in
the inverse auto regressive flow model.
So this is actually a very effective way
to deal with it.
The same kind of independence problems
we saw that we're addressing on the
decoder side,
but they're addressing it on the encoder
side.
So you can kind of see just briefly what
this is doing.
So this is your prior distribution.
Ideally you would like sort of the
marginal posterior,
which is sort of like combining all
these things together to be as close to
this as possible because any sort of
disagreement between those two is really
a modeling error.
So it's an approximation error.
So standard vie model is going to get
going to learn to do something like
this,
which is,
it's kind of as close as it can get to
this while still maintaining
independence in the distributions.
Using this I f method,
it's a bit of a complicated method that
involves many,
many iterations of transformations that
you can actually,
um,
compute that are actually invertible
that.
And you need this to be able to do the
computation.
But with that you can get this kind of
thing,
which is pretty much exactly what you'd
want in this setting.
So we've played around with this model
and in fact,
you know it,
we find it works really well in practice
actually.
Um,
yeah,
so,
but it's,
again,
it's on the encoder side.
What we were doing with the Pixel va's
on the is working on the decoder side.
Um,
but now,
so this is actually fairly complicated.
Both these models actually fairly
complicated to use and a fairly
involved.
So one question is,
is there another way to train this model
but isn't quite so complicated?
And,
uh,
so,
at the time a student of Yoshua Bengio
and I,
uh,
Ian goodfellow was toying around with
this idea and he came up with a
generative adversarial nets.
And the way generative adversarial nets
work is it posits the learning of a
generative model g,
um,
in the form of a game.
So it's a game between this generative
model g here and a discriminator d.
So the discriminators job is to try to
tell the difference between true data
and data generated from the generator,
right?
So it's trying to tell the difference
between fake data that's generated by
the generator and true data from the
trending distribution.
And it's just trained to do so.
This guys trained to try to output one
if,
if it's true data and output zero.
If it's fake data and the generator is
being trained to fool the discriminator
by using its own gradience against it
essentially.
So we back propagate the,
the discriminate,
the discriminator air all the way
through through x.
We usually have to use a continuous x
for this and into the discriminator.
Now we're going to change the parameters
of the,
of the generator here in order to try to
maximally fool the discriminator.
So in us,
sort of a more uh,
um,
uh,
I guess abstract way to represent this
looks like this.
So we have the data on this side.
We have the discriminator here with its
own parameters.
And this,
again,
for our purposes,
those almost always a convolutional
neural net.
And then we have the generator,
which is again one of these kind of
flipped convolutional models cause it
takes noises,
input,
it needs noise because it needs
variability and then it converts that
noise into something.
An image space that's trained with these
parameters are trained to fool the
discriminator.
All right,
so you know,
we can be a little bit more formal about
this.
This is actually your objective function
we're training on.
So let's just break this down for a
second.
So from the discriminators point of
view,
what is this?
This is just,
it's called the cross entropy loss.
It's literally just what you would apply
if you're doing a classification with
this discriminator.
That's all this is from the generators
point of view,
the generator comes in just right here,
right?
It's the thing you draw these samples
from and it's trying to minimize while
the discriminators trying to maximize
this quantity,
this is essentially likelihood,
uh,
and,
and the discriminant the generators
moving in the opposite direction,
right?
So we can analyze this,
this game to see,
you know,
this is a question,
right?
Does,
well,
you know,
actually the way this happened was,
um,
at first he just tried it and it worked.
It was kind of a overnight kind of thing
and we got some very promising results.
And then we set about trying to think
about,
well how do we actually explain what
it's doing?
Why does this work?
And so,
uh,
we did a little bit of theory,
which is useful to,
to discuss.
And I can tell you there's been a lot
more theory on this topic that's been
done that I will not be telling you
about.
But it's actually been a very
interesting development in the last few
years.
But this,
this is the theory that appeared in the
original paper.
So that the way we approached this was,
let's imagine we have an optimal
discriminator.
This turns out you can eat pretty
easily.
Show this is the optimal discriminator
up here.
Now you couldn't,
this is not a practical thing,
right?
Because we don't know pr,
which is probability of the real
distribution.
We don't,
this is not available to us.
This is only defined over training set.
So only by training examples.
So we actually don't,
we can't instantiate this,
but in theory,
if we had this optimal discriminator,
then the generator would be trained to
minimize the Jensen Shannon divergence
between the true distribution that gave
rise to the training data and are
generated distribution.
So this is good,
right?
This is telling us that we're actually
doing something sensible in this kind of
nonparametric ideal setting that we
don't,
we're not really using but,
but it's,
um,
but it's actually,
it's interesting nonetheless.
Um,
so one thing I can say though,
that in practice,
we actually don't use exactly the
objective function that I was just
describing.
What we use instead is a modified
objective function.
And the reason is,
is because if we were to minimize,
Gee,
what we had before was this term
minimizing g,
what happens is,
is that as the discriminator to gets
better and better,
that the gradient on g actually saturate
it goes to zero.
So that's not very,
uh,
useful.
If we want to train this small,
and this is actually one of these,
one of the practical issues that you see
when you actually train these models is
that you're constantly fighting this
game between the,
you're,
you're sort of on this edge of,
of the discriminator doing too well or,
or the generator,
uh,
you know,
it's a,
it's,
it's essentially,
you're basically almost always fighting
the discriminator because it's always
going to,
as soon as this discriminators starts to
win this,
this a competition between the gender
and the discriminator,
you end up with unstable training.
And in this case,
you end up with basically the,
the generators stops training and the
discriminator runs away with it.
Well,
that's actually in the original case.
So what we'll do instead is we optimize
this,
which is a slight modification,
but it's still monotonic and it actually
corresponds to the same,
the same fixed point.
But,
but what we're doing is we're just
actually with respect to g,
again coming in through the samples here
or maximizing this quantity rather than
minimizing this one.
Okay.
So that's just a practical kind of
heuristic thing,
but it actually makes a big difference
in practice.
All right.
So when we did this,
when we published first published this
paper,
this is the kind of results we would see
and what you're looking at now is kind
of movies formed by moving smoothly and
zed space,
right?
So this is,
you're kind of looking at
transformations on the image manifold
coming from smooth motions in zed space.
So we were pretty impressed with these
results again,
and maybe they felt good at the time.
Um,
but there's been,
you know,
a few papers that have come out
recently,
well,
not so recently.
Actually at this point in 2016 there was
a,
this was came out in 2014 and 2016 there
was a big jump in the quality.
Um,
and,
and this was sort of one of those
stages.
This is the least squares Gan.
This is just one example of many I could
have pointed out.
Um,
but this is the kind of results we're
seeing.
So,
so part of one of the,
one of the secrets here is that it's one
28 by one 28.
So bigger images actually give you a
much better perception of quality in
terms of the images.
But so these are not necessarily,
or generally not real bedrooms,
these are,
these are actually generated from the
model,
right?
So trained on,
you know,
roughly I think 100,000
or at least a hundred thousand bedroom
scenes asked to generate from these
random zed bits.
This is what it gives you.
So one thing you could think of,
one thing that's certainly kind of
occurred to me when I first saw these
kinds of results is that well it's just
over fit on some small set of examples
and it's just learning these Delta
functions,
right?
So,
so that's not that interesting.
In some sense it's kind of memorize some
small set of data and it's enough that
it looks good and it's impressive,
but it doesn't seem like that's actually
the case in one of the evidence.
One of the parts of evidence it was
pointed to,
and this is in the DC Gann paper,
um,
was this,
so that same trick that I showed you
with the movies in damnest where where
we were sort of moving smoothly and zed
space,
they applied basically that same idea
here.
So this is basically one long trajectory
through zed space.
And what you can see is starting up here
on the ending up all the way down here,
when you can see it's a smooth
transition,
right?
And at every point it seems like,
you know,
a reasonable bedroom scene.
Okay.
So it really does seem like,
like that picture that I showed you
where we had the zed space,
it was sort of smooth and then we had
this x space,
they've had this manifold on it.
It really does feel like that's what's
happening here,
right,
where we're moving smoothly and zed
space and we're moving along the image
manifold in x space.
So for example,
this,
I guess,
I don't know if this is a picture or tv,
but it slowly morphs into a window I
guess,
and then kind of becomes clearly a
window and then it turns into just into
these edge sort of an edge of the room.
So one of the things actually if you
want to nitpick about these,
the models actually don't seem to
understand three d geometry very well.
It often gets the perspective just a
little wrong sort of something might be
interesting for future work.
Um,
so yeah.
So one question,
uh,
you might be,
it's a why,
why do these things work well?
And they keep in mind that,
you know,
when we talked about the v model,
we actually had to do a quite a bit of
work to get comparable results,
right?
We had to embed these,
pick these,
a pixel CNNS and the decoder,
or we had to do some quite a bit of work
to get the encoder to work right in
these models.
We literally just took a confident stuck
in some noise at the beginning,
pushed it through and we got these
fantastic samples.
It really is kind of that simple.
So what's going on?
Like why is it working as well as its
wills?
It,
it is.
Um,
and so I have a kind of an intuition for
you.
I kind of a cartoon view.
Um,
so imagine that this is the image
manifold.
So,
so this is kind of a cartoon view of an
image,
a metaphor,
but like this is in,
in two pixel dimensions here.
And,
and we're imagining here that these are
just parts of image manifold and they
sort of,
you know,
share some features close by.
But,
but what this is basically representing
is the fact that that most of this space
isn't on the image manifold,
right?
Image manifold,
some complicated nonlinearity and if you
were to randomly sample in Pixel space,
you would not land on this image
manifold,
which makes sense,
right?
Randomly sample in Pixel space,
you're not getting a natural image out
of it.
This is sort of a cartoon view or my
perspective on the difference between
what you see with
maximum likelihood models of which the
va is one and something like a Gan.
So the maximum likelihood,
the way it's trained is it has to give a
certain amount of likelihood density for
each real sample.
If it doesn't,
it's punished very severely for that.
So it's willing to spread out it's
probability mass over regions of the,
of the input space or the or of the
Pixel space,
which actually doesn't correspond to a
natural image.
And so when we sample from this model,
that's most of boy our samples come
from,
right?
This is,
these are these blurry images that we're
looking at again,
models things differently,
right?
Because it's the only playing this game
between the encoder and,
well,
sorry,
between the discriminator and the
generator,
all it has to do is sort of stick on,
you know,
some subset of the examples or maybe
some subset of the manifolds that are
present and not have enough diversity
that the discriminator can't notice that
it's modeling a subset.
So there's pressure on the model too to
maintain a certain amount of diversity,
but at the same time it doesn't actually
face any pressure to model all aspects
of the training distribution.
It can just ignore certain aspects of
the training examples or certain aspects
of the training distribution without
significant punishment from the,
from the training algorithm.
So anyway,
that's,
that's I think a good idea to have in
your mind about the difference between
how these methods work.
Um,
yeah.
So,
so just I'd like to sort of conclude
with a few steps that have happened
since the,
uh,
the gains.
One of the things,
this is something that we've done.
We've actually,
you know,
you might ask,
well gans are great,
but in a way it's kind of unsatisfying
because we start with [inaudible] and
then we can generate images.
So yes,
we generate really nice looking images.
But,
but we had this,
you know,
a hope when we started talking about
these latent variable mount models that
we could actually maybe infer the zed
from an image,
right?
So we can actually extract some
semantics out of the,
of the image using these latent
variables that you discover and in
again,
we don't have,
then the question is can we actually
within this generative adversarial
framework,
can we re incorporate inference
mechanism?
So that's exactly what we're doing here
with this work.
And this is actually a model we call
alley,
but they,
the identical work essentially came out
at the same time.
Uh,
I'll known as by again.
And the basic idea here is just to
incorporate in encoder into the model.
So rather than just giving the data,
distribute the data set,
or here on,
on the left or earlier,
the Gan was defined,
we had the decoder or generative model.
But over here,
we only gave it x training examples.
And here we only compare it against x,
uh,
generated from the,
from the j the generator.
But in this case,
what we're doing is we take x and then
we actually use an encoder here to,
to generate a zed given x.
And on the decoder we have again,
our traditional Ganz style.
We take us said sample from some simple
distribution and we generate x.
So again,
this is the data distribution over here
and code it to zed.
And then we take our decode the sample
from zed and we decode to x.
And our discriminator now crucially is
not just given x,
but it's given x and zed.
And it's asked,
can you tell the difference in this
joint distribution between the encoder
side and the decoder side?
That's the game.
And what we find is,
well first of all,
it actually generates very good samples,
which is interesting.
Uh,
it's actually,
it seems to generate sort of better
samples and we see with comparable gans,
which there might be some regularization
effect.
I'm not entirely sure why that would be,
but actually it gets fairly compelling
samples.
This is just with a seller bay,
a large data set of a celebrity images.
Um,
but this is the more interesting plot.
So,
so this is actually corresponds to a
hierarchical version of this model.
So this is why we have multiple sets.
So this is ed one and said to,
this is a two layer model inversion of
this model.
So if we just reconstruct from the
higher levels Ed,
which is this,
you know,
containing fairly little information
because is this you?
It's a single vector and then it has to
synthesize into this a large image.
What we're looking at here,
a reconstruction.
So we take this image,
we encoded all the way to zed two and
then we decode it.
And what we end up with is,
is this,
which is,
you know,
reasonably close but not that great.
Right?
And so as the same thing,
you're going to kind of all,
they sort of hold some piece of the
information,
which in some sense this is kind of,
it's remarkable that does as well as it
does because it's actually not trained
to do reconstruction.
Unlike something like the vie which
actually explicitly trained to do
reconstruction and this is just trained
to match these two distributions.
And this is kind of a probe to see how
well it's doing.
Cause we take x from one map a to zed
and we take that set over and when we re
synthesize the acts and we see we're
seeing now an x space,
how close did it come?
And you know it does.
Okay.
But over here when we give it x one ends
ed too.
So in this case we're really just giving
it all of the latent variable
information.
We actually get much,
much closer.
Which is interesting because this is
telling us that this pure joint
modeling,
in this case it'd be a joint modeling
between x,
Y,
zed one ends,
zed to that.
This is enough to do fairly good
reconstruction without ever actually
explicitly building that in.
So it's giving us an interesting probe
into how close are we coming to learning
this joint distribution and it seems
like we're getting actually surprising
the clothes.
So it's like it's a testament to how
effective I think this generative
adversarial training exam algorithm
actually is.
So I want to just end with a few other
things that have nothing to do with our
work but I think are very,
very interesting and well worth you guys
learning about.
So first one is cycle Gan cycle again is
this really cool idea starting with,
let's imagine you have two sets of
datasets that somehow correspond but you
don't know the correspondence you don't
have,
like there's an alignment that exists
between these two data sets,
but you might not know what,
you might not have paired data.
This actually happens a lot.
Say for example,
this is not an image space,
but a great example of this happens in
machine translation,
right?
You almost always have lots of
unilingual a data.
So just text data in in a given
language,
but it's very expensive to get aligned
data.
But to data paired as a source and
target distribution.
If the question is what can you do if
you just have unilingual data,
how successful kicking you'd be at
learning a mapping between the two.
And they essentially use gans to do
this.
So this is the setup.
They have some domain x here and her
domain.
Why here?
And what they do is they start with an
ex,
they transform it through some
convolutional neural net,
usually a resonant based model into some
y.
And on this why they're going to
evaluate it as a,
as a,
as a Gan style discriminator here.
So Ken acts a through g make a
convincing why that's being,
what's being measured here.
So you can think of x is taking the
place,
which is some other image.
Let's say this is some image to another
image.
This image x is taking the place of our,
of our zed,
of our random bits.
It's getting it's randomness from x.
And then we do the same thing.
We can kind of transform it through f.
So we've got x here,
transform it through g,
t to D and we evaluate on,
on the our discriminator here on Gann
style training.
And then we re encode this annex.
Now once we get here,
that's over here.
So we've taken ecs transformed it into
why transform it back.
They actually do what's called a cycle
consistency loss,
which is,
this is actually a reconstruction.
This is an l one reconstruction error
and they back prop through f and g and
then they,
it's a symmetric relationship.
So they do the exact same thing on the
other side.
They start with why they see if they can
transform it into acs,
the compare the,
they compare that that that generated x
with true x is via a discriminator.
And then again transform that to y and
do the cycle consistency loss.
So without any pair of data,
this is the kind of thing that they can
get.
So a particular note is a horses and
zebras,
right?
So,
and this is a case where,
you know,
it's,
it's impossible.
Do they get this kind of pair data?
Say you wanted a,
a transformation that transformed horses
to zebras and vice versa.
You will never find pictures of horses
and zebras in the exact same pose,
right?
That's just not a kind of Datas that
you're ever going to be able to collect.
And yet they do a fairly convincing job
of doing this.
And you can see that they even turn like
there's a little bit,
this one actually doesn't do it very
well,
but oftentimes what you see as the turn
like green grass a little bit more
savannah like you took that kind of
dulls it out because zebras are found
generally in Savannah,
let conditions,
uh,
they can do a winter to summer kind of
transitions.
I've seen examples data night,
um,
these are pretty interested in the
various other things.
Now I think there's,
there's a lot of interesting things you
can do with this dataset.
And,
and going back to,
if you think about that simulation
example with ro robotics that I gave the
motivating example at the beginning.
This is a prime application area for
this kind of technology,
but it will say that one of the things
that they've done here is they assume a
deterministic transformation between
these two domains.
So I think there's a lot of interest
looking at how do you actually break
that kind of restriction and imagine
something more like in many to many
mapping between these two domains.
So the last thing I want to show you is
kind of the most recent stuff,
which is just kind of mind blowing in
terms of just the quality of generation
that they,
they show.
So these are images from invidia
actually.
So I don't know if I'm,
I'm uh,
I'm sort of a undercutting,
I don't know if he was going to show
these or not,
but uh,
yeah,
so these trained on,
um,
on the original,
celebrate data set,
the same one we had before,
but now much,
much larger images.
Right?
So 1,024
by 2024 and they're able get these kinds
of uh,
generated models.
So I would argue that many of these,
maybe all of the ones shown here
essentially pass a kind of a,
a turing test,
right?
An image turing test.
You cannot tell that these are not real
people right now.
I shouldn't say not all images actually,
uh,
look this good.
Some of them are actually really spooky,
but you can go online and look at the
video and pick some out there.
Yeah.
Um,
how they do this is with a really
interesting technique and this is
actually a so new,
we,
I have students that are starting to
look at this,
but we haven't really probed this very
far.
So I actually don't know,
uh,
how effective this is in general.
But it's actually seems very
interesting.
So they just start with a tiny four by
four image and once you train up that
parameter,
those parameters for both the
discriminator here and the generator.
So again,
these are convolutions but we're
starting with,
with a relatively small input,
we increased the size of the input,
we add a layer and,
and,
and the,
some of these parameters here actually
formed by the parameters that gave you
this image.
So you sort of just stick this up here
and now you add some parameters and
you'd now train the model to learn
something bigger and you keep going and
you keep going.
And then you get something like this.
As far as I'm concerned,
this is this sort of,
this amounts to kind of a curriculum of
training does two things for you.
One is it helps build a bit of global
structure to the image because you're
starting with such low dimensional,
um,
inputs.
It,
it helps reinforce the kind of global
structure,
but it also does something else,
which is pretty important.
It allows the model to sort of,
um,
not have to spend a lot of time training
a very,
very large model like this.
Right?
You sweet.
I would imagine they spend relatively
little time training here.
Although this is Nvidia,
so they might spend a lot of time
training this,
but um,
but it allows you to spend a lot of the
time sort of in much,
much smaller models,
so much more computationally efficient
to train this model.
All right.
So that's it for me.
Thanks a lot.
Oh wait.
Oh yeah.
Sorry.
One more thing I forgot.
Uh,
this is just what they get.
Unconditional image.
A generation now with amnesty.
So this is again,
so you give it horse and then it's able
to generate this kind of thing.
So far it's able to generate this,
right?
So bicycles,
it's able to generate these,
which is pretty amazing.
Um,
quality.
Uh,
if you zoom in here,
you can actually,
it's kind of fun because the,
it kind of gets the idea of,
of,
uh,
these,
these spokes,
but not exactly like some of them just
sort of end midway.
Uh,
but yeah,
but still a pretty,
pretty remarkable.
All right.
So,
uh,
thanks.
If they have questions,
I'll take them.